just skin and bone they're being
completely fully Oh God it was just as
if they've been left to their fate it
was just desperation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we had heard from our ring contacts that
there were people trapped on a beach in
Myanmar it sounded almost fanciful even
though they were absolutely confident
that the word people trapped there
because no one had seen them we didn't
know for sure they needed to go they
independently because no one's allowed
to reach that place and we wanted to do
that to see for ourselves as what is
happening to these people the question
was always getting the access to hidden
you know it was almost impossible I mean
you know Burma Myanmar whatever it was
and has been a closed country for
decades you know so so physically
getting in there is almost impossible
almost as soon as we set off one of the
true-blue the failing water out of the
bottom I look down and the hole at the
bottom was filled with several inches of
water what is this button doesn't do
very well on on boats I'm not a great
swimmer personally I'm also so the
person has been seasick in a harbor and
a pedlow so getting into a boat and
getting on the sea it's actually one of
my big fears but of actually drawing it
it was absolutely pitch-black you
couldn't see anything till moon rose and
then there was a little bit light on sea
these people have relatives over there
they were evading the Bangladeshi Coast
Guard evading the Myanmar authorities
and their Coast Guard landing safely and
evading the Myanmar troops and then
doing it all back again
signaling
they'd likely flash from the shore
several things sort of went through my
head straightaway I thought well that's
gonna mean we can land because the
Myanmar soldiers wouldn't be flashing us
in and trying to guide us in and then
secondly I thought there's obviously
people there
[Music]
okay just give you a hand
[Music]
well you can see already there are
people gathered on the shores and
there's quite a business of of people
making their way out to boat first thing
we saw was a raft actually in the water
all these people here and then we sort
of swung back again it was my
person-to-person three people 10 people
20 it was just just this the sea of
people you can see there's absolute
chaos who was what looks like hundreds
of people trying to get away from here
they saying that Marines have been laid
just further on everyone in a state of
desperation they're begging us to take
them away he's making me hold the baby's
leg very very thin they're all very thin
and you can see how desperate they are
people are holding their hands out
Oh
I really wasn't expecting so many people
I was really stunned that there were so
many I thought there might be a few
dozen maybe they told us that there were
a few hundred and I thought they were
wildly exaggerating at all a lot of them
extremely thin and very frail showing
extreme signs of desperation they want
help they want help they're crying out
for help
it was so dark and there were no lights
anyway you had to be really up against
people to see them I could see better
than Alex and Evelyn because of the
infrared I was probably the only one
that could see everyone else was sort of
literally grouping around in the dark
trying to you know watch upon footstep
and I've got this sort of fantastic
crystal-clear view albeit in this green
world think the rest the team would have
picked up the noise whereas I could
physically see this is quite a sizable
crowd here and we'd only just arrived
you know one of the people I saw was
this very very frail woman I was just
drawn to her because she was very very
thin look at her I can put my entire
hand round just Skinner being completely
fully gaunt how she was physically able
to stand diseases still it's quite
surprising I mean she was just there was
nothing to very weak stable people
absolutely shocking
we all knew we had a very short period
of time on the beats and you had to
stick together we were having to hold on
to each other so that we wouldn't get
separated and get lost in the darkness
and in this mass of people they were
pulling and tugging at us and begging
and crying it was just desperation
[Music]
weak incredibly weak really very sick
they were anxious to show us look
there's babies look there's sick repeat
then look those people who've been
beaten up look we're having to build her
own rafts they were really really
anxious to show us as much as possible
[Music]
[Music]
screaming it was just as if they've been
left to their fate with the hand
stretched out asking for help
this quite was quite heartbreaking
how old is this one tube in there and
here's another baby how old is this one
today today she looks a mess a young
[Music]
they'll pretty much frightened of
everything frightened of the soldiers
frightened of the scene frightened of
being left there begging us to take one
with us we created quite a stir because
we'd arrived by boat which meant they
could get on that boat and there was
suddenly hope for them
and this is the result the UN calls a
cleansing they have been pushed into
this position simply because there are
Kingdom Muslims I think they all felt
that we have come to rescue all of them
unfortunately that was not going to be
the case we have a limited number on the
boat itself for us to be choosing what
level of the tiles was a really hard and
terrible choice but whoever we felt the
most vulnerable with the new bonds and
the old was a difficult choice but there
was no other choice I think okay okay
we're being told to leave now never wait
to go to force
girl over here
look away
[Music]
suddenly on the boat everyone went quiet
there was just so many emotions going on
you know that book as it sort of made
its way slowly back of the coast
everyone was exhausted
they were very hungry and the crew was
handing out biscuits and water they were
looking like they'd been through some
awful long nightmare it was an
incredibly difficult story for all the
journalists to cover because they
weren't being allowed access to the
areas where all the accusations were
coming from although there was this tide
of people coming over you had to take
their word for everything they said and
this allowed the Myanmar authorities to
deny a lot of it and just say well these
people are lying they're making it up it
didn't happen the Burmese military and
its government is lying to the world
this was evidence of what is actually
happening to these people the whole
thing about fake news being put out by
the rest of the media and everything was
made up was actually untrue
the most important thing a journalist
team can do is to go and get that
evidence provide it right in front of
them and say right try and deny that
[Music]